hi I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
going to talk about my sixth form um so
my sixth form is cyos sensei's second
form analogous to similar to again I hit
some slightly different points than he
hits um hopefully I'll explain all the
points for you to get today uh I'm going
to call Josh out here we're going work
Josh all right so let's talk about my
sixth form cyto say's second form okay
so in this form again so now that we're
into this series uh everything's going
to be from Joe Kamai here on out as far
as she goes um Josh is going to be in
ski Kamai and we're in Josh's range
remember when we talked about um four
and five we talked about that the ideal
would be this because it requires very
little for me um however if I'm in a
panick state I'm probably not going to
do something so refined so I'm also very
likely to just do this in a panicked
State now in form two um the UK is just
coming in now of course we could or
sorry cyto senses to my my six um so we
could um have Josh go back after this
right so I could go like this and Josh
could hop back and he could use the
jodon guch in order to do that right um
but in this he's going to be coming in
so maybe his expectations are that I'm
going to hop back and then he's going to
chase me down and and and come get me
that jodan gu huge but what I do is I
very quickly am able to fire off a chusi
so as he comes in here I fire this chusi
off okay so what Josh does is he doesn't
have time to make adequate distance and
get out of the range of that so he just
uses the transition of jodan Sho kind of
like you would in UK Nash and he comes
off to the side right so as I fire in he
gets off to the side okay now he's going
to launch the rest of that jodon guch
but because he's close he's not gonna go
to my head he's just gonna go to my leg
because we're close quarters and we see
that last form too that we go to this
low position and last form the way I
dealt with it was I went back like this
okay but in this form it's going to take
too much time because as I'm turning and
stepping and all this he's likely to get
me before I'm able to get there so all I
do is I turn my weapon over right here
so as he goes boom I turn my weapon over
right here okay now my front is open to
him and so as my front's open he just
subz comes in there I clear that away
and I come here to the side and that's
the whole form okay so basically What's
Happening Here is I'm caught a little
unaware mentally so I have a panicked
reaction but I am quickly able to shoot
back in with that chusi and as I do Josh
slides right by that like an UK Nash now
he goes ahead and finishes his action
going for my leg I defend that now my
front section's open he comes in I knock
that aside and I come here now the knock
to the side depending on what's going on
may be more or less necessary so if
we're here and Josh is
like yeah there we go Josh is like this
if I'm quick enough that with every
action I just just get offline and
that's generally the way site though
since I shows it I don't have to do a
defense but if I'm a little behind I can
defend here as I step off to to make my
new uh position cyi doesn't show that as
far as I know but um as a teacher I'm
often doing things as slowly as humanly
possible and when my students realize
what we're doing then they often go as
lightning fast as possible so I have
lots of little ways to deal with their
crazy explosion of violence and that's
one of them right so if you're a lot
slower than the other person you totally
can defend your midsection here um all
subai and when we get to the spear
section we'll talk about that but so
this is my sixth form CTO sensei's
second form analogous to that um I'm
Christopher hind Joshua my McDaniels
behind that camera right there see you
in the next video